there's a lot going on in star wars
episode 9 which means that some
characters were bound to fall by the
wayside as others took the lead in the
closing chapter of the saga here are
several characters with relatively small
roles in the rise of Skywalker along
with why each one ended up with such
limited screen time
the force awakens introduced viewers to
an older wiser Leia Organa now a general
leading the resistance against the first
order Leia continued in that role in the
last Jedi but actress Carrie Fisher
sadly and suddenly died in 2016 after
completing work on that film director JJ
Abrams opted to use several minutes of
Leia footage left over from the force
awakens for the rise of Skywalker
so Leia is present throughout most of
the film as the leader of the resistance
but the limited Fisher footage meant
that she was often shown simply
observing and reacting to other
characters the dialogue scenes she does
have are short and with the help of
movie magic Abrams engineered a somber
meaningful death scene for her character
lots of fan favorite characters from the
original trilogy including Han Solo Leia
Organa and Luke Skywalker returned in
the force awakens but what about Hans
old pal and the suave astute in the
galaxy Lando Calrissian Lando didn't
make his return until the rise of
Skywalker and it's easy to see why with
both Han Solo and Luke Skywalker dead
and Leia Organa pulling limited duty the
film needed another rebel legend to turn
to in the end though that's pretty much
all Lando is there for an intended
subplot about Lando meeting his
long-lost daughter was reportedly cut
out of the film leaving him to just look
cool saying a few catchy lines and to be
an inspirational figure for the younger
heroes when it was announced that Mark
Hamill would return to reprise the role
of Luke Skywalker for the force awakens
fans were excited but then learned he
only appeared on screen in the final
scene the last Jedi gave Luke a lot to
do but it presented a divisive version
of Luke Skywalker capping things off at
the character's redemptive death fans
were excited to find out Hamill would be
back for the rise of Skywalker but
surely he couldn't do that much as a
force ghost right he does appear at a
key moment in the story when Rey is
doubting herself and contemplating a
self-exile similar to Luke's own he
dispenses some wisdom then shuffles back
off into the afterlife after that he
does some voiceover that's the entirety
of his role in the last Jedi one of the
most important new characters was rose
Tico a resistance mechanic who ran into
Finn and struck up a friendship that led
to a mission and even a hint of Romans
rose shows back up in rise as a mainstay
of the resistance
unfortunately that role apparently also
came at the cost of her screen time as
Rey Finn and Poe head out for their
mission early in the film Rose explains
that she can't come because Leia has
asked her to stay behind
she then disappears for much of the rest
of the film before fighting in the
Battle of Exile according to co-writer
Chris Terrio Rose's role in the film was
initially beefier but had to be cut down
because of special-effects issues he
told Awards daily we wanted Rose to be
the anchor at the rebel base who was
with Leia as the process evolved the few
scenes we'd written with rose and Leia
turned out to not meet the standard of
photorealism that we'd hoped for those
scenes unfortunately fell out of the
film maz kanata's presence in the force
awakens raised a number of questions
about why the cantina owner and former
smuggler knew so much about the force
and how she had possession of Luke
Skywalker's lightsaber those questions
never really got answered after a brief
appearance in the last Jedi Maz appears
at the resistance base in the rise of
Skywalker where she stays for pretty
much the entire movie without really
contributing much to the plot she
functions almost as a Greek chorus using
her wisdom and knowledge of the force to
help give the audience some context for
Leah's final struggle then popping up
during a final celebration to give
Chewbacca a medal when Finn Poe and Rey
make it to the Endor system they come
across a group of warriors who agree to
help them get to the debris of the
second Death Star to find what they're
looking for these Warriors are later
revealed to be deserter stormtroopers
who've made a life for themselves
stripping their old first order ship for
parts to get by their leader Jana has a
conversation with Finn about
shared aspects of their pasts Jonah is a
fascinating character with a lot of
potential depth but she doesn't really
get a big chunk of screen time she gets
early moments on end or establishing who
she is then hangs around with Finn
throughout the final battle but we don't
really learn what her real desires are
other than to fight the first order
there's a hint of what she does next in
a very ambiguous scene with Lando at the
end of the film a likely holdover from
the cuts subplot where she was meant to
be Lando's daughter when Finn Poe and
Rey head out for their mission to find
Palpatine the gang takes c-3po and bb-8
along for the trip but leave r2d2 behind
at the resistance base r2 is thus
relatively quiet until he flies into
battle with Poe at the end of the film
why leave r2 arguably the most iconic
and beloved droid in the franchise back
at the base for much of the film well in
many ways r2 has always felt like Luke
Skywalker's droid and with Luke out of
the picture for so much of the sequel
trilogy r2 doesn't always fit as it
turns out rise of Skywalker is much more
of a showcase for Threepio s place in
Star Wars lore and considering bb-8 has
become the unofficial mascot of the
sequel trilogy the filmmakers likely
chose to give a little more screen time
to that little toy yet iqbal droid to
close out the series where do you come
from check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about Star Wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]